it is cruel to only have four minutes
with the two of you I'm going to jump
right into it so both of you have
obviously accomplished so so much in
this genre that even with all that
experience while you're watching the
final film while you're watching
Insidious The Red Door is there any
particular like scene visual or tiny
detail that makes even you guys go like
damn I cannot believe we made that
happen
geez the cat the the the MRI CAT scan
scene for me is definitely pretty pretty
cool that uh that was actually uh Lee's
idea was a great idea for me I would say
uh the most exciting thing for me was
seeing Patrick pull the entire family
unit back together because that was the
most exciting part for me is because I I
worked with Patrick uh as an actor in
the first two films and so I I got to
fall in love with with with you know the
Lambert family and uh you know with
Patrick's character with Rose's
character and all the kids kids and so
it was really good to see them now all
grown up and that for me was the most
exciting part was uh just seeing you
know seeing them seeing Patrick
exploring more of his family's character
Dynamic and uh and see where he kind of
takes them now in in this new chapter as
someone who's been a die-hard fan of
this franchise since 2010 that was a big
winning element for me as well I adored
that
um so I was just talking to Patrick and
he was singing your Praises in terms of
how well supported you both made him
feel so can you maybe give me an example
of something seemingly small you did for
him so that he could bring his vision to
screen that you know maybe could be
something other producers Overlook but
it's actually really important and could
make a big difference on other first
first time feature director films out
there we we allow we we allowed for a
more generous schedule than um I think
the the the the James will tell you the
system is so screwed up because the you
the more experience you have and the
more successful you are as a director
the longer a schedule you need and
actually the revert the people who need
a longer schedule are first-time
directors because they don't know what
they're doing they don't know what's
going to wind up in the movie and not
they need time to experiment experience
directors they know so I think one of
the small things that we did is allow
for a longer schedule for him to have
because because he was a first-time
director yeah and and for me it was
really just being there for Patrick as a
sounding board he was just takes me at
all hours of the day with ideas and
thoughts and stuff like that and I'll
just kind of respond to him I'll get
back to him if like oh yeah that's cool
what about this what about that and we
would just sort of Bounce our geese back
and forth and I think um that was the
kind of collaboration I had with Lee and
I went to to kind of a fort Patrick that
as well and and you know whether it was
the script or the story or designing of
the Demons you know the sort of um the
craft of camera work and all that stuff
I just wanted to be there for him and so
uh so that he felt like you know he can
pretty much ask me anything if he needs
anything I like the idea of paying that
forward in that in that respect
um I will wrap with a big uh franchise
type question for both of you because
you have both had a significant amount
of experience of continuing franchises
so can you maybe each give me one do and
one do not you apply to considering
whether or not to add another
installment to a long-running franchise
foreign
clearly I mean don't make another
installment of the if the last movie
didn't work don't make another one
that's a don't
[Laughter]
yeah I I would say the dues
um that uh that you know if you think
you know like I I if you have something
else to tell I think that's very
important if you believe that you have
the next chapter and you have an
interesting unique story that's really
the main thing for me you both have a
good track record in that respect I am
always going to keep coming back for
more congratulations on the red door
guys thank you